ما نعرفه هو أن ما لا يقل عن 21 شخصًا
لقوا حتفهم بعد اندلاع حريق
ومستشفى في بكين يوم الثلاثاء
وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الإخبارية التي تديرها الدولة، ونعلم أن
الحريق اندلع في حوالي الساعة الواحدة ظهرًا بالتوقيت المحلي
يوم الثلاثاء وتم إخماده بعد حوالي نصف
ساعة  في وقت لاحق، تم إجلاء 71 مريضًا
ولكن للأسف لم يتمكن الكثير منهم من الوصول الآن،
هذا الفيديو الذي نشاركه معك
الآن يظهر لك أن شخصًا واحدًا كان
قادرًا على الخروج من المستشفى من خلال
النافذة باستخدام ملاءة السرير، هذا الشخص
يتسلق من النافذة ويهبط عليها  هيكل
يشبه السقف يندفع إلى
سطح مبنى مجاور
بحثًا عن الأمان النسبي، ولكن لاحقًا في هذا
المقطع الذي تم تداوله على نطاق واسع على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في الصين، نرى آخرين
يحاولون الخروج، يمكنك رؤيتهم
هناك وهم يجلسون بشكل خطير على
وحدات تكييف الهواء هذه بالخارج  في انتظار
المساعدة وCNN، لم نتمكن من تأكيد
أننا لا نعرف ما إذا تم إنقاذ هؤلاء الأشخاص
أم لا